it's not about discrepancy series what
we have been talking about so far is
that about something this means if I
have the random number generator in
general examples and this is the sample
that I'm going to use and many many
additions were thinking thinking that we
could perhaps too much better than that
because what I would be looking for is
Hemisphere and I'll be shooting samples
on the surface on this Hemisphere and
create unit vectors on the surface of
this Hemisphere and I can do this
deterministically what if I have an
algorithm that doesn't generate random
numbers but it will make sure that this
time is the a if I have 100 samples the
samples are well distributed on this
hemisphere and if you do this you may
get much better convergence and much
better looking result so below you can
see a random number generator generating
samples in candy and after the whole
tone sequence which is called enrollee
frequency series what this means is it's
not completely randomly but it tries to
fill the space reasonably but this isn't
map video if you read after it what you
would think is that it would it would be
very simple to get a grid and just put
points in the mid point and then you
would have samples are really wellness
committee and this you can do it truly
this you can do in one line
stakes of this works there but there are
mathematical rules and that this is
absolutely certain in higher dimension
so if you're higher dimensional spaces
then this is a 12 stratified so the most
commonly used sequences are the outer
series so whole series of water quality
series we can do this little discrepancy
sampling in many different ways
and this
Matta gives you an even distribution of
the noise because you are sampling these
hemispheres reasonably reasonably
stratified with so it cannot really be
that one side of the hemisphere sampled
almost exhaustively and the other one is
is completely neglected so you would get
images with a noise distribution that's
better for you so that's a plus but what
is even more important is that it is
deterministic so if you render it an
animation imagine completely rendom
something we have frame number one you
distribute your suppose that comes very
manually and then you distribute your
samples in a completely different way so
the noise would look like this of anyone
and death completely different so until
you have converged perfectly you will
have these issues that before
tako flickering with a coherence issues
because the noise looks like this on
frame or looks like that of a loop and
and if you pay twenty five of these
frames every second or maybe even more
then you will add with really this
problem in crater you are computing
everything and the football series and
all all discrepancy series help you with
them so they like to use the same
industry because of this reason because
even subsequent frames will compute the
very same advantages okay disadvantages
well
disadvantages are also huge it's often
map reveal if you take a look at this
image these walls are not textured these
are one color dream this is one color
green if used well and this is a one
power you shouldn't feel a bit like this
at all
this is a image and I have
implemented the amount of support and
the problem that I encountered was for
for eventing conventions and this is a
serious problem that you can encounter I
will not go into the details but you
just mess up with one small detail and
you can get an image like that well this
is actually the delightful way of
failing I don't know about you but most
of my primary areas are necessarily
supportive like this they tend to look
like this so I usually segmentation
and stuff like that so it's if you make
a mistake in mobile illumination
wondering even your errors but you
better than in other fields